i'm now the fourth united states
president
to preside over american troop presence
in afghanistan
i will not pass this responsibility onto
a fifth
i spoke yesterday with president bush to
inform him of my decision
i've concluded that it's time to end
america's longest war
it's time for american troops to come
home the consequences
they're pretty obvious fracture the
government fracture the afghan security
force the possibility of the taliban
taken over
and an absolute disaster and what do we
have to go back in
and do it again like we did in iraq
general jack keane responding there to
the decision to pull all
all troops out of afghanistan by
september 11th of this year
let's bring in our panel ben dominic
publisher of the federalist
leslie marshall democratic strategist
and trey gowdy former congressman from
south carolina
trey let me start with you there are two
sides to this coin obviously the trump
administration as we mentioned last
night
was trying to do this by may 1st and it
was popular
politically when when the president the
former president now
would talk about it on the campaign
trail bringing troops home
but there is real concern especially in
the
hawkish uh kind of side of the
republican party about what happens
afterwards you brett i'm glad you
brought that up i mean
our response should be the same and
luckily for me mine is i mean
no is the war over or is just our
participation
in the war over i i mean i'm not moved
by the number 20 years yes it's a long
time but
so is 17 years so is 12 years i mean
there's nothing
talismanic about 20 is the threat of
terror it was a war on terror
is the terror threat over what are our
intelligence officials telling us what
are our military officials
telling us that's what i want to know so
he's got to make the case for
why are you doing it and why now
leslie i guess there are some people who
said that every time we said it was
conditions based the conditions never
got there
and at some point some president had to
do what biden's doing however
congressman mike waltz from florida who
served uh
as a special uh forces soldier over in
in afghanistan multiple times had this
to say
the last thing i want to see is another
911
and the best way to i think cause
another 911 to happen
is to pull all of our troops out of
afghanistan
when half the world's terrorist
organizations are still there
leslie well if we just look at
al qaeda they are are definitely not the
al-qaeda that we
knew on uh 9 11. the taliban might be
stronger quite frankly than they were
when we first
entered afghanistan but here's the
problem brett um
you know a lot of vets who fought in
afghanistan
uh don't feel that way and do feel that
there are going to be risk whether we
stay or whether we go because
in staying in our presence there we do
not solve the problems that plague
afghanistan i mean the afghan government
wasn't even present for the negotiations
which the taliban were
but speaking of the government is
stronger but more specifically
the military of afghanistan is stronger
their special operations and
intelligence are stronger
joe biden didn't just campaign on this
as you know when he was vice president
he fought former president barack obama
and failed
about this very issue so this is
something a lot of
americans want certainly there are those
i like to see the consistency who are
against this in the republican party
with donald trump
as they are with joe biden i think it's
risky either way
but we just can't stay there because of
a potential
threat from an outside terrorist group
al-qaeda
al-qaeda more than the taliban which
certainly is more of a concern within
the borders of afghanistan
yeah and ben leslie rightly points out
that
president trump plowed the political
field here that made it a lot easier for
president biden to make this decision
you know i have had multiple family
members serve in afghanistan
and what they'll tell you along with
many of my friends in in this generation
who have gone there
uh is that this is long past the point
where we should have left and that there
is
diminishing returns toward being there
and i think that one of the real
issues where washington is completely at
odds with the american people
is this war it has been a repeated
problem in terms of anyone who tried
to engage in a process that would lead
to leaving president trump had to do it
over the
objections of all manner of people
within washington
he obviously set that may first deadline
which is now being moved back
and in talking to some people who are
veterans of that conflict today
many of them were telling me that they
think that this can kick is only going
to lead
to future excuses that will keep us in
that country for the foreseeable future
that in in the interim in the time
between now and this
uh 911 choice of of exit
that there will be all manner of
justifications made for us to stay there
and honestly i can't really dispute them
on that given what we've seen in so many
other instances
of our foreign policy over the past two
decades
well not only that but when you put a
date on the calendar and the date
happens to be 911
it seems like some people may take
advantage of that or try
in afghanistan to change the
circumstances i want to talk about the
circumstances
on the southern border we reported trey
earlier that the vice president is
heading to guatemala and mexico
the northern triangle countries as well
to
deal with what she calls the root causes
and she said that's what the president
has asked her to do
she is not however going to the southern
border
the last time she did go to the southern
border she talked about that experience
a couple of times take a listen
the president
what is happening with the detention of
these children
the circumstances by which they arrived
is a human rights abuse
being committed by the united states
government when elected the first thing
i'm going to do one of the first things
is to shut down these private detention
facilities a private detention facility
that currently houses seven hundred
children
i saw children lined up single file
based on gender
being walked into barracks the policies
of this administration have been
facilitated
by laws on the book that allow them to
be incarcerated as though they've
committed crimes
so i mean is that why they're not going
to the southern border because of those
sound bites
and the exponential number of kids down
there now
you know brett i mean if she's looking
for the root cause
of our migration crisis i can save her a
trip to guatemala just go to her own
campaign website i mean if you want to
know why people are coming to the
southern border listen
to the way democrats have talked about
this country and the republican party
no wall very little border security
we're going to decriminalize access to
this country
sanctuary cities are fine you're going
to have to do a heck of a lot to get
deported
i mean that's why they're coming so so
now she doesn't need to go to guatemala
i can tell her belize is doing well
costa rica is doing well panama's doing
well there are plenty of countries in
that region
they're coming here because of people
like her and the way they talk about the
issue
leslie i'll give you the last word it's
fair to point out that vice president
pence focused on northern tribal
countries too
and and those countries working with
them not to
produce people coming to the southern
border but this is different
is it not well certainly it's different
it's a different
administration in a different way look
we don't want to just write checks to
the government we want to make sure that
the people can benefit
how can the people benefit how do we
stop them from coming from el salvador
honduras and guatemala specifically
uh that those countries are just ridden
with crime and poverty
how do we work with these governments
and by the way the president of el
salvador last week wouldn't meet with
the u.s special
envoy would he even meet with the vice
president who should visit
all of those countries not just to and
certainly should go to the border as
well
but the the bottom line is you have to
stop the source
and quite frankly democrat republican
going back haven't done that
and hopefully this administration can be
successful in that
we should also point out we invite vice
president harris and president biden to
come on special report pretty much every
week
it's a standing invite so that continues